if you can't sit silently with yourself
with your thoughts then you are not
living in intentional examined life and
I think to be addicted to your phone or
to be living in that reactive mode where
you're constantly distracting yourself
robs you of something that we need as
human beings which is rumination and
boredom that is the juice of creativity
and as a creative person somebody who
does this show and talks to amazing
people and is writing a book and is very
much in a space where your creativity is
really the driver of everything that you
do I would say to you it is of Paramount
importance to protect your boredom to
protect your quiet time to put
boundaries around those distractions
otherwise you are not going to be doing
your best work and you are going to be
depriving your audience of the best
version of yourself